in other
in other
uh kevin mccarthy news which is not
quite as funny as him selling t-shirts
uh calling themselves morons
uh nancy pelosi has actually called
kevin mccarthy out for something serious
i'm gonna read from this insider article
pelosi office rips into republicans for
terrorizing capitol police after trump
called officer a murderer
now donald trump still has his little
blog his little website where he issues
statements
uh how does he phrase them
statement by donald j trump
45th president of the united states of
america sounds real official on his
little blog uh reading from the insider
before we get to that though a
spokesperson for house speaker nancy
pelosi on thursday excoriated
republicans after former president
donald trump called a capitol police
officer a murderer
as he continued to whitewash the deadly
january 6 insurrection that he incited
the former president's threat against a
u.s capitol police officer is only the
latest in a long line of vile republican
attacks on the officers who risked their
lives to protect the united states
capital on january 6. in recent weeks
republicans have slandered these
officers as executioners and murderers
and insulted their intelligence and
integrity on national television
spokesperson robin patterson said in a
statement enough
is enough patterson said officers
present that day who have called out the
partisan efforts to downplay a violent
insurrection have been subjected to
death threats and racist abuse no member
of house republican leadership has
bothered to condemn this harassment or
speak out in support of these officers
patterson went on to say pelosi
spokesperson said gop efforts to malign
capitol police officers are disgusting
wrong and a wholly unacceptable way to
treat the officers who went through hell
to protect our democracy from armed
insurrectionists the article wraps here
patterson said it's long overdue for
minority leader kevin mccarthy to get
off his hands and stand up to the
members of his congress and party who
have been terrorizing the brave officers
that saved the lives of countless
workers staff journalists and members on
january 6th it's no less than these
heroes deserve
and of course kevin mccarthy's office
did not respond with comment
so what what sparked this was this
statement from donald trump on his
goofy little blog site
where he said this
i spoke to the wonderful mother and
devoted husband of ashley babbitt who
was murdered
at the hands of someone who should never
have pulled the trigger of his gun
we know who he is
if that happened to the other side there
would be riots all over america and yet
there are far more people represented by
ashley who truly loved america than
there are on the other side the radical
left haters cannot be allowed to get
away with this
there must be justice
there is veiled threatening language in
that statement
we know who he is
listen
ashley babbitt was tragically killed
by police
while she was in um
in an attempted overthrow of the united
states government
she endeavored to overturn a free and
fair election she attempted in the
middle of a riot a violent overthrow of
the government she attempted to enter
the house floor through a broken window
of a barred door
a blocked door
if she had entered
who knows what other insurrectionists
would have made it into the united
states
house chamber
and who knows what kind of carnage what
kind of violence what kind of melee
would have taken place
ashley babbitt was an adherent of q anon
the same conspiracy theory group that
believes hillary clinton
ripped off the face of children and
drank their blood to imbue herself with
the power of adrenochrome or some other
nonsense
q anon is dangerous the federal
government has warned
that there is a threat of domestic
terror surrounding people who believe
the theory
it is not something to take lightly
actually babbitt was not murdered
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
pacman